[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
buenas tardes
buenas tardes y vamos a ir subiendo el
nivel energético que como decía mar
estamos llegando ya al ecuador muchas
gracias muchas gracias y padres siempre
nos decía de bien nacido es ser
agradecido
y yo sólo he transmitido a mis hijas y
se lo transmito a todo el que quiera
escuchar
es importante ser agradecido y en estos
momentos incluso tenemos que agradecer
pues el estar vivos estamos pasando
momentos que nunca habíamos pasado por
lo menos los que estamos aquí vivos en
estos momentos
y a mí me gustaría comenzar con una
historia de la confianza la encontré
hace 20 años
me fui a hacer un doctorado en la
universidad complutense yo estaba el
profesor en la autònoma en madrid y de
repente un profesor me habló de
confianza y digo eureka esa es la clave
es que puede haber alguna relación
que no haya confianza tiene sentido eso
es que viviría con alguien en quien no
confía 6 no es fácil
empecé a investigar qué pasaba en las
empresas en las organizaciones hasta qué
punto se confiaba unos en otros el nivel
de confianza es bajo y todas las
investigaciones te dicen que cuanto más
sube es arriba a la cima menos confianza
hay entre la gente que está ahí lo cual
es terrible porque dice seguro que
entonces no estamos aprovechando el
talento que hay
si no hay confianza el talento no aflora
el miedo es un reductor del talento y
hablamos muchísimo de talento comencé a
investigar el tema escribió un libro y
de repente me encontré a confucio y
confucio aparentemente dijo yo no me
atrevo a asegurar quién dijo y quién lo
dijo
para gobernar hacen falta tres cosas
armas comida y confianza
y si no se pueden dar las 3
elimine ese primero las armas y después
la comida digo qué bárbaro confucio y
había escrito un libro sobre confianza
ahora escrito hasta cinco libros sobre
confianza y que hice metí la frase de
confucio y cómo era para gobernar se lo
mandé al presidente del gobierno a la
moncloa
y es verdad que me contestaron yo no sé
si la secretaria el software o un
jardinero que pasaba por allí
pero profesor de saia el tema de la
confianza es muy importante
ya lo sé yo
después que dice hacer un seguimiento
del presidente de gobierno durante seis
meses
no se lo leyó
o no entendió nada
porque la confianza no es una cuestión
de palabras la confianza es una cuestión
de hechos de comportamientos
y entonces empecé a desarrollar un
modelo lo apliqué en una empresa en
brasil otra en el país vasco aquí en
españa y era un modelo de competencias
vamos a ver que a través de qué
comportamientos podemos inspirar
confianza porque a todos nosotros nos
encanta inspirar confianza a los demás
no es cierto servirnos de confianza
y después de desarrollar el modelo me di
cuenta que me faltaba un tema
fundamental el tema de que si tú quieres
inspirar confianza comienza trabajando
tu autoconfianza
y ahí quiero dedicar la mayor parte de
mi tiempo
y nivel de autoconfianza tenemos
hay un problema con la autoconfianza no
es como el título de bachiller si
tenemos el título de bachiller lo normal
es que ya lo tengamos para siempre a no
ser que venga un ministro de educación
raro que tal como está el tema podría
venir y nos quita a todos el título de
garcía esperemos que no pero con la
autoconfianza resulta que tú estás hacia
arriba
y te pegan para ti y te pegan para ti te
pegan para ti y te vas allí abajo y dice
josemaría esto he hecho una [ __ ] filia
y ahora como me levanto
es tremendo tenemos que estar trabajando
continuamente la autoconfianza porque
entre otras cosas nuestras abuelas y
abuelos se van muriendo y ya nos han
dejado de decir pero qué guapo eres
con lo cual va a depender de cada uno de
nosotros
yo os voy a dar una herramienta de cinco
elementos para que trabajes esa
auto-confianza cuando esté un poco más
bajo primer elemento autoconcepto
y en los talleres que suele desarrollar
digo escríbeme una línea del concepto
que tienes de ti misma de ti mismo soy
una persona responsable listo y guapa
bueno pues muy bien pues ya has puesto
eso y ahora yo te pido que reflexiones
si ese autoconcepto lo tienes desde
siempre hoy hace cinco años que pensabas
de ti
y cuando eras pequeño que te decían en
casa y te decía tu papá que te decía tu
mamá hasta el maestro que tuviste
y vamos viendo cómo hemos recogiendo de
unos y otros y nos hemos hecho un
autoconcepto mi autoconcepto cuando era
pequeñito era un desastre total
yo era debilucho pequeñajo asquerosos y
yo
y además mi madre se llamaba mamá ya
sabes que no me meto contigo sino que te
pongo de referente se llamaba peregrina
da pena mourinho
y no seáis cabrones no reír os
peregrina la patrona de pontevedra
tenéis que ir el segundo domingo de
agosto unas fiestas maravillosas
esa es la nota publicitaria
mourinho apellido muy gallego pero el
problema fue la pena que me lo pasó
es decir yo me llamo josé maría gasalla
da pena
imaginaros en el colegio
y nos llamamos por los apellidos
y a mí no es que me llamasen gasalla da
pena es que lo mejoraban los hijos de
[ __ ]
me llamaban gasalla da lástima
para que no hubiese dudas
pero no había bullying y cosas de esas
santos que tenía que aguantar y salir
adelante
y yo normalmente en mis conferencias
suelo salir con un balón de baloncesto
porque a mí el baloncesto me salvó y me
metí en el equipo del colegio y empecé a
funcionar y me hizo que mi
auto-confianza empezase a sufrir para
arriba primera revisión autoconcepto
segundo parámetro
autoestima josemaría no es lo mismo que
autoconcepto no autoconcepto es que
pienso yo de mi autoestima es
como me quiero
josemaría bien el fin de semana un par
de cubatas caen lo hicieron muy bien no
seas ese no es un indicador los cubatas
te voy a pedir y por favor reflexionar
los colocase en la escala de vuestros
amores que significa que pongáis arriba
de toda la persona que más a mainz
y la segunda y la tercera y la cuarta
josemaría puedo poner mis dos niños al
mismo nivel no uno debajo de otro
primero mi santísima madre
después está mi niña julieta y mi niño
periquito
después mi marido aunque de vez en
cuando lo bajo al 9 al 10 es un poco
cabrito
también un vecino que está muy rico en 5
y yo las 6
y difíciles que nos coloquemos arriba
del todo
josemaría pero es que sucedía
egocentrismo egoísmo quien te lo ha
dicho
es tremendo nos han dicho muchas
mentiras
y otras verdades que nos olvidamos
porque también nos han dicho aquello de
amar al prójimo como a quién
y se nos olvida yo siempre pongo la
metáfora de la mascarilla de oxígeno del
avión en caso de despresurización de la
cabina saldrá una mascarilla o es que no
tiene fuertemente de ella aplicación
sobre su nariz y su boca y si va con un
niño más pequeño
aplíquese la primera vez y después al
cabroncete del niño
y algunos dice yo no vuelvo a viajar con
estos de ryanair primero mi hijo quien
que se va a cargar a su hijo primero
usted
después su hijo ha entendido bien
fijaros un tema yo creo que no se puede
dar lo que no se tiene
y no se puede amar si tú no sientes es
amor dentro de ti y es amor no es el ego
no ese capricho es que hablando de amor
de verdad
pensar en el tema de la autoestima
porque uno de los mayores problemas que
hay en la comunicación son personas con
baja autoestima llenas de miedo y
pensando que todos les quieren atacar
tercer elemento autocrítica autocrítica
que significa pues que es lo que resalta
en ti cada uno de nosotros como somos
por favor que levante de brazo un
poquito de luz a la palestra ahí que
levanten el brazo las personas
singulares
levantar el brazo a las personas
singulares por favor
bueno aquí hay una hay dos y ahora que
levanten el brazo los mier de sillas
y repito la votación por si alguien
quiere cambiar
pero como nos puede costar reconocer que
cada uno de nosotros es único es
singular
y por supuesto también discapacitado yo
soy un discapacitado igual que cada uno
porque nos falta alguna capacidad seguro
pero lo primero que hay que reconocer es
que tengo yo especial dentro de mí que
puedo aportar
y también que haría de mejora esa es la
autocrítica yo suelo pedir dos
fortalezas y un área de mejora cuarto
elemento auto eficiencia auto eficiencia
que son los logros los logros cuando
estéis un poco bajos pensar en los
logros que habéis conseguido en vuestra
vida cantidad de logros habéis superado
aquella adversidad y superado la falta
de un ser querido que se nos ha ido ha
superado a tele examen que pensaba que
era imposible ganar una carrera
increíble como vanessa bueno pues es que
es todos tenemos grandes logros lo que
pasa y cuando estamos un poco bajos lo
único que vemos es negritud
es importante trabajar esa auto
eficiencia y finalmente autodisciplina
para mí es clave la autodisciplina es el
punto de arranque para el auto liderazgo
y el auto liderazgo es el punto inicial
para el liderazgo a otras personas
tenemos que liberarnos porque si no nos
lideramos a nosotros mismos va a haber
alguien que lo intente hacer y
seguramente no con las mismas
intenciones que tú
y ese es el modelo para trabajar yo lo
trabajo a nivel de coaching de entre dos
personas venga vamos a empezar a hablar
de todo esto en la línea del tiempo cómo
ha ido evolucionando y qué es lo que me
ha ido sirviendo en la vida veamos lo
positivo nuestro querido sistema
reptiliano está cargado de negatividad
porque esa es su función ver los
peligros las amenazas la psicología
positiva que dice que cualquier nueva
realidad busca lo positivo porque seguro
que lo tiene
y quiero ir terminando
en este momento hubiese esperado una
reacción del público que dijese no a
nada
bueno voy a repetir para la oportunidad
y quiero ir terminando
y me gusta terminar con una historia de
vida
una historia de admiración y
reconocimiento con tres reflexiones
sobre la admiración
primera reflexión cuando admiras a
alguien nunca sintáis que os colocáis
debajo de ese a alguien que sois menos
que sea alguien hay personas que mira
consumaría yo no admiro a nadie que es
han creído pero si nadie se ha creído
nada
primera reflexión segunda si tenéis
admiración por alguien y yo estoy
pensando en el padre en la madre o
cualquier otra persona un profesor un
maestro o lo que fuese por favor pasar
de la admiración en abstracto a la
admiración en concreto es decir no
digáis no le admiro no le admira hacen
que en esto en esto en esto le admiro
porque es un gran profesional le admiro
porque es honesto le admiro por lo que
sea cual miro a mi mamá por esto y por
esto y por esto
porque porque esos sirven de guías de
vida a vosotros mismos y tercera
reflexión sea miráis a vuestro padre y a
vuestra madre y tenéis la suerte de que
están vivos uno de ellos o los dos
por favor que si se lo que le queréis te
quiero papá y te admiro en esto en esto
y en esto te quiero mamá y también en
esto esto estoy esto
que dice no ser más generosas a veces
somos muy parcos en la expresión de las
emociones positivas
yo esto lo siento profundamente
seguramente porque no se lo dije
suficientes veces a mi madre ya mi padre
y mi padre
fue una persona a la que admiré
tremendamente por su autodisciplina
brutal y a mi madre por su sensibilidad
por su a morosidad y por la paciencia
que tenía por con mi padre
porque mi padre fue un tipo muy singular
y os cuento rápidamente su historia
nació en una pequeña aldea del interior
de galicia donde no había nada había
iglesia pero no había escuela y se tenía
que ir por el monte 89 km todos los días
a una aldea vecina y volver por allí no
había ni carretera nba nada y tener una
casita humilde humilde que nunca hubo ni
agua corriente ni agua corriente tenía
una cuadra eso sí y mi abuela tenía unas
galletas una cabra su padre se murió
siendo el muy joven analfabeto se murió
un padre
y la madre mi abuela
era se murió analfabeta pero era muy
lista
que venza ahí seguramente ese pequeño
era yo
pero otro señor era mi padre
y sabéis dónde estábamos
en el miradero
de toledo debajo de la
plaza de zocodover porque yo nací en
pontevedra pero al año de vida a mi
padre le destinaron actores y tuve la
gran fortuna de vivir en un sitio
maravillosa en la plaza de zocodover
zocodover 51 tercero ve todavía me
acuerdo
increíble hice la primera comunión en
las ursulinas y después ya le destinaron
a madrid nos fuimos a madrid
y entonces mi padre y mi abuela decidió
que tenía que salir de allí el hijo de
la aldea allí no hacía nada y a los 14
años no reunió el dinero para irse los
dos pero le metió algún barco y lo mandó
a mexico a casa de un vecino que decía
que le daría trabajo y que seguiría
estudiando
y fue muy emigrante que se fue a los 14
años y estuvo hasta los 22 pero no hizo
fortuna incluso dice que lo robaron el
día anterior a [ __ ] el barco digo
menuda borrachera debías haber cogido
cabrón
y volvió a pontevedra y allí se puso a
trabajar en una tienda de ultramarinos
conoció a mi madre se casó con ella y
tuvo cuatro hijos y siempre decía lo que
más deseo es que mis hijos vayan a la
universidad en el país una oposición de
hacienda y le destinaron a pontevedra
pero después otra le destinaron a toledo
y terminó haciendo todas las oposiciones
pero no pudo ir a la universidad hasta
que se jubiló y a los 70 años entonces
dice ahora es el momento y se fue a un
sitio en madrid se llama el ceu san
pablo estudiar derecho
y ahí don manuel iba todos los días a la
primera fila a [ __ ] nota primero
segundo tercero cuarto eran cinco años
le da una cosa de corazón y termina la
carrera a los 76 años el expediente
manchado de disgusto al año siguiente el
curso de práctica jurídica alcalá de
henares y todo orgulloso de la medalla
que le dio
fernández ordóñez a los 77 años y ahora
lo que había es teoría estudia lo que me
gusta la contabilidad le encantaba la
contabilidad claro había estudiado para
las oposiciones y se hace auditor
y empieza a trabajar con empresas a los
80 años para auditar empresas de amigos
y es 83 84 85 años de repente un día
llegando a casa de ellos no a las 10 de
la noche y mi madre sólo no están gente
ahora se acaba de matricular en una
academia y te va a estudiar ahora a los
83 años 84 no dice que ahora va a
estudiar para el futuro
que se fue a estudiar informática
e inglés porque él decía que sin eso no
había futuro y acaba de una correa va
conmigo en inglés tal cual y a los 87 88
años como vio que yo había estudiado
varias carreras yo yo no quiero ser
menos que el cabrón de mi hijo
y como era una persona con
con mucha fe
dice que me voy a estudiar ahora era muy
creyente y dije ahora me voy a estudiar
teología y a los 88 años don manuel se
iba a clase todos los días sacó una
asignatura dos de primero no consiguió
terminar primero 89 años otra de segundo
90 años se matrícula a una judaísmo
cristianismo islamismo todavía me
acuerdo
[Música]
y ahí pasó lo que nadie puede evitar que
su compañera mi madre su esposa de más
de 63 años juntos se nos fue a otro
plano
y él prácticamente dejó de tomar las
pastillas para el corazón para el pulmón
dice dejo ir con ella
pero he tenido la gran fortuna
de estar muy cerca
de un joven de 90 años
porque la juventud está fundamentalmente
aquí en nuestra cabeza
y ese es mi deseo con el agradecimiento
nuevamente mi deseo para todos vosotros
que sigáis siendo siempre
muchísimas gracias
[Música]
bien
bueno
[Música]
aquí